My husband mentioned that he was craving Coca Cola the other day,
and since we were out of soda,
I decided to make him some today.
I started by making my caramel sugar by combining some water and sugar,
letting that come to the hard crack stage
before pouring it out and letting it cool.
Once it was all cooled down,
I broke it up and set it aside and moved on to zesting my citrus.
I started by zesting some oranges,
some lemon, and lastly I also zested some lime.
I moved on to grinding up all of my spices.
I started by combining some nutmeg, cinnamon,
some vanilla, coriander seeds,
rose hip, some lime leaves,
and some coconut before grinding that into a fine powder.
I combined the last round of ingredients
which were some water with different sugars,
citrus that we zested earlier,
and we can't forget about our citric and malic acid
and also the caramel sugar we made earlier.
I set that into a water bath
and let that all come together
for about an hour and a half on the stove
before straining it through a fine mesh strainer.
Pop that in the fridge until it was cold
and then it was time to have our soda.
I combined some Cola syrup with sparkling water
and this tasted exactly like Coke,
and when I made lucky a glass
he was so impressed that he had to have another glass after.